thanks yesterday yes we are indeed with
the man of the yard the five-time world
champion vishwanathan Vichy last year in
Poland you started three out of three in
fact in the first day of Rapid today two
and a half a pretty decent start tell us
about uh your day yes uh very nice start
um
with alireza
he
um at some point I was losing control
because I went to Bishop D4
and I think that's a mistake I had
simply missed uh perhaps we can get that
through that game going on
Bishop to D4 yeah somewhere on that
so he
walked in permitted this move
yeah he commented Knight G4 and of
course I could play E5 and maybe it is
unpleasant for him after version by four
and just play E5 and it should be
but I got Grady and I thought if I throw
Bishop D4 in and after E3 Bishop takes
C3 and then E5 is very strong but then
that's very nice yeah
yeah but um
Bishop takes C3 by the way yes sorry
yeah
so uh key
but he found he played Knight C4 and
then I realized there was a hole in my
calculation because after E5 there is
simply E3
now
kind of wondered about e takes F4
but it I I felt in the end it might it's
more likely to be wrong than right yeah
so is it because of the structure no
it's just I'm losing this Pawn I have a
little potential on the king side let's
say fg3 had G3 and then maybe the queen
transfer to H5
but I couldn't really believe that this
would work so then I decided to bail out
with Bishop takes B2
yes
and I think he could take with the
g-pawn
I thought the e-pawn was fine as well
but the J gives a more potential when
something is taken like already I can't
play Queen D5 because of H3 and group
takes C5
this this trick this trick is happening
quite often in the game
so
what also I didn't realize is I come to
an igf6 here because of Rook takes C5 so
I'm not I was kind of just paralyzed
there so then I came up with the Rook FC
egg
and then realized I had not solved H3
Knight F6 Rook takes C5 at all yeah so I
just Blended right back into that
so yeah well you can see it was a
chaotic game but then at some point he
just blundered Queen D4
but I think
it's pretty close to equality I would
say yeah so in the end he wasn't risking
very much but
um
so this one finished in yeah the only
draw uh in today's rounds for you but
then obviously it's so important to
finish on high note and you did that in
a very difficult game because it's so
easy to liquidate everything and just
make a draw in this type of positions
yet with limited material you managed to
convert well he does London I mean he
went through okay phone I mean Rook
takes B3 and he was a little bit shocked
yes uh I think it just slipped his mind
so but even here with the corner I did I
didn't even think it was really winning
yeah I thought the edge must be very
small so okay one I missed wish B5 I
mean queen before Bishop A3 Queen B7
looked
weak to me I couldn't really believe
that apron's gonna go anywhere yeah but
you know as long as it's alive it's
bothering him but we went for this and
then I'm just doing Miracles not lose
the air Pawn so I what did I come up
with I went came up with Queen B5 that's
a very nice
take take
it
it there might be a there might well be
a good move like Queen C4 rocking F1
which might be better than what he did
with instead of going to explain like
King F1 is a great move to throw in
first of all it leaves me with an a pawn
a rather weak upon and uh
but not least and you know why this king
is improving but not yet right not yet
not yet but uh I'm threatening Bishop
takes B8 and Rook takes A6 so
uh
yeah but the problem with this position
is enough there isn't a draw but you
know when you're playing with white you
need to nail it and that's that's where
the hope for me came
so I and one thing I've noticed you were
also putting a lot of pressure on your
opponent's uh clock you're playing very
very fast
so I found Bishop before
at this point
6.4 yes
um
the one I have to take yes he takes and
then I go B4 and this pawn it looks like
it should fall but again with my Knights
I'm going to do some Bishop d694 is a
nice trick but he starts with The Rook
yes
and then I have to stop 966 I briefly
considered E5 but sorry so Rook C8
okay
but he could have played ah so he wanted
to play something else and I'm still
threatening uh the thing Checkmate yeah
so so what if he goes F3 here
I would
play now you have Rook season four
Knights
no here actually I considered Rook C to
Roxy one check King F2 Knights save her
yeah and again by Miracle I'm not losing
that pawn but I would have had to check
everything at the board because you
could easily blunder into a background
thing yeah in fact I've just blundered
into it take C5 Knight C2 yes it's not
even right yeah
so it's the margin of error is oh no I
have Rook D5 here but that pawns read
not gonna it's not long for this world
so
um
so he played Rook to B2
and 95 is a good trick here because Roxy
to I simply call 9c3
and there is no way he can and then if
the Knight comes to D3 and so on I'm
really connecting with us together
nicely yeah
so he took this into an E4 and now he
just has a bad choice he can play 85 and
D6
and you know with my e-pawn there's some
hope but I would say decent winning
chances for black yeah yeah yeah and
what he did
went down very fast
yeah after that yeah in fact here I
realized that um I after G4 I really
ought to have known this
fj3
okay King James
and then take a king for all the long
walks here there the Hedge Pawn might
drop and so on I think I think they
should be winning but what I did was
fine as well I mean I
somehow keeping the hedge fund also was
very tempting yeah
here and his problem is he has gone G5
if you didn't I would play F6 in King G6
but now that he's gone there I'll take
on H3 and what happened to the game
you're just coming off a very intense
tournament as well the global chess
league if it was like all of the players
that are warmed up in this event do the
yourself Magnus who are performing well
or coming from that tournament do you
feel playing more before uh helped you
as well for me it made a huge difference
because I got a chance to play chess
after a fairly long break so for me the
global chess League was very useful to
remember how to play chess and
well I wouldn't draw too many
conclusions from one day let's I mean I
hope this continues but let's see
tell me about the gokish you've been
mentoring this young Prodigy for quite a
long time we've seen you give him a lot
of advice during events as well tell us
a bit about him
so in 2020 when I started my Academy
there were these four young Grandmasters
very very young and they were all at the
age of 14 15 thereabouts
I mean I expected them to make huge
leaps anyway but particularly
um
gokesh has done very very well Prague
also had a sensational year I think it
wasn't fully reflected because he was
playing more rapid and Blitz than
classical so his classical rating wasn't
budging but now he's making up for that
but gukesh is very very impressive he's
just one of the he's now the top 15 or
something and that's fantastic for him
and he had a very incredible result in
Norway so
yeah very happy that he's doing well
Wishy congratulations once again on a
great start to this tournament and we'll
see you tomorrow thank you
thank you Christian